ich konnte es es nicht glauben dass so
etwas nach dem
Holocaust noch einmal geschieht diese
Bitterkeit diese Hass Liebe verehrte
Margot
Friedländer so haben Sie Ihre Gefühle
geschildert über das Grauen das sich vor
nun vier Wochen in Israel ereignet hat
wir können nur erahnen wie sehr gerade
sie die Ereignisse Schmerzen müssen
liebe Frau Friedländer sie die sie den
Holocaust überlebt
haben umso dankbarer bin ich umso
dankbarer sind wir Sie heute hier
begrüßen zu dürfen und möchte Ihnen noch
einmal ganz herzlich zu ihrem Geburtstag
zu gratulieren den sie gerade erst
gefeiert haben 102 Jahre liebe Frau
Friedländer was für eine
Lebensspanne herzlichen Glückwunsch von
uns
allen
ich freue mich dass Sie alle liebe Gäste
heute hier im Schloss belvü zu diesem in
der Tat besonderen Gespräch gekommen
sind ein erstes Gespräch
über das Zusammenleben in Deutschland in
Zeiten des Krieges im Nahen Osten ein
Gespräch dem weitere Gespräche mit
anderen Teilnehmern und anderen
Schwerpunkten Folgen werden sie alle die
sie heute hier sind sie alle leb
Zusammenhalt und sie alle machen uns mit
ihrem Beispiel Mut in diesen ernsten
Zeiten Mut wie unser Zusammenleben
gelingen kann seinen sie uns alle
herzlich willkommen liebe
Gäste seit dem 7 Oktober ist in Israel
nichts mehr wie zuvor für die Israelis
ist der Terrorangriff der Hamas eine
zesur und ein tiefes Trauma zugleich
Raketenangriffe bestialische Morde
Verstümmelungen
geiselnamen haben zu einem neuen Krieg
geführt das Bangen um die
Geiseln hält an ein Krieg den die
Hammers auch gegen die eigene
Bevölkerung führt die selbst zur Geisel
geworden ist tausende unschuldige sind
ihm bereits zum Opfer gefallen und das
Leid der
Menschen berührt uns im
Innersten der Krieg hat auch
Auswirkungen auf uns unser Land auf
unser Zusammenleben in Deutschland wir
spüren es alle unser Land unsere
Gesellschaft ist gefordert wie lange
nicht ich bin erfreut über die große
Solidarität mit Israel aber ich bin
besorgt wie sehr die Gewalt im Nahen
Osten auch den gesellschaftlichen
Frieden in Deutschland gefährdet und ich
bin entsetzt über die Billigung des
Terrors die antisemitische Hetze auf
unseren Straßen
und ich verurteile das scharf und
entschieden meine Damen und Herren
morgen ist der 9
November und es ist unerträglich dass
Jüdin und Juden 85 Jahre nach den
progrommen des 9 November
1938 sich nicht sicher fühlen in unserem
Land dass sie Angst haben ihre Kinder
zur Schule zu schicken dass Hausfassaden
mit dem Davidstern beschmiert
werden ich möchte mich an die jüdische
Gemeinschaft in Deutschland wenden und
sagen die Gewalt gegen Jüdin und Juden
in Israel hat sie bis ins Mark
erschüttert ich weiß das es ist wie ein
Albtraum der sie seit einem Monat
gefangen hält und ich kann Ihnen das
Entsetzen über aggressive
judenfeindliche Kundgebungen in
Deutschland nicht nehmen
aber ich will Ihnen versichern dass
dieses Land nicht ruhen wird solange sie
um ihre Sicherheit und Sicherheit ihrer
Kinder fürchten müssen wir werden
Antisemitismus in unserem Land nicht
dulden keinen alten und keinen neuen
keinen christlichen und keinen
muslimischen keinen linken und kein von
rechts und ich möchte mich auch an die
palästinensische Gemeinschaft in unserem
Land wenden sie alle sollen Raum haben
um ihren Schmerz und ihre Verzweiflung
über die zivilen Opfer in Gaza zu
zeigen auch mit anderen zu teilen das
Recht das öffentlich und friedlich zu
tun ist von unserer Verfassung
garantiert und dieses Recht steht nicht
in
Frage es darf keinen antimuslimischen
Rassismus und auch keinen
Generalverdacht gegen Muslime geben
aber Terrorismus
verhetzung der Aufruf zur Vernichtung
des Staates Israel sind nicht Teil
dieser
Garantie und ich erwarte dass wir
gemeinsam dagegen halten die Hamas
spricht nicht für die PalästinenserInnen
und
Palästinenser im
Gegenteil sie werden selbst Z Opfern des
Hamers Terrors und ich bitte Sie die
Menschen mit palästinensischen oder
arabischen Wurzeln in Deutschland lassen
Sie sich von den Helfers Helfern der
Hammers nicht
instrumentalisieren sprechen Sie für
sich selbst und er teilen Sie dem Terror
eine klare
Absage liebe Gäste ich verstehe dass
viele Menschen auch in unserem Land
bangen
hoffen dass sie um Angehörige und
Freunde fürchten dass sie Mitleiden mit
den Menschen auf der einen oder auf der
anderen
Seite und vieles davon spiegelt sich
wieder in Briefen und E-Mails die mich
in diesen Tagen in zahlloser Größe
erreichen wir spüren die innere
Zerrissenheit vieler die auf die Straßen
gehen und wir spüren auch die scheinbar
unüberbrückbaren
Differenzen zwischen einzelnen
Gruppen dass wir auch in Zukunft
friedlich zusammenleben können das ist
aktuelle
Herausforderung
und gleichzeitig die große Aufgabe vor
der wir in der näheren Zukunft stehen
und zwar
alle und ich glaube es ist auch das was
sich die meisten Menschen in unserem
Lande wünschen ganz gleich woher sie
kommen und an was sie
glauben das Deutschland von heute ist
ein weltoffenes vielfältiges Land wir
sind ein
Land mit Migrationshintergrund in dem
Menschen mit ganz unterschiedlicher
Herkunft mit unterschiedlichen
Erfahrungen
Religionen Zusammenleben in einem
solchen
Land hat gesellschaftlicher Friede
Voraussetzung das Fundament unseres
Zusammenlebens ist das Grundgesetz das
Freiheit für alle garantiert Bedrohung
und Diskriminierung aber
ausschließt gerade die versammlungs und
Meinungsfreiheit sind hohe Güter
festgeschrieben in unserer Verfassung
friedliche Proteste Solidarität
Mitgefühl all das ist
legitim und Ausdruck
verfassungsrechtlicher Freiheit
aber aber die Freiheit hat dort ihre
Grenzen wo sie in Gewalt und Hass
umschlägt antisemitische Volksverhetzung
Angriffe auf Synagogen das Verbrennen
israelischer Flaggen sind keine
Wahrnehmung von Freiheit als Straftaten
müssen sie strickt verfolgt und bestraft
werden wer in diesem Land lebt und leben
will der muss die die Regeln für das
friedliche Zusammenleben respektieren
und der muss ja der muss auch wissen um
unsere Geschichte ich habe es kürzlich
am Brandenburger Tor gesagt und
wiederhole es heute wer in Deutschland
lebt muss Ausschwitz
kennen und die Verantwortung die daraus
für uns erwächst jüdisches Leben in
Deutschland zu schützen ist
Staatsaufgabe
ja aber es ist auch Bürgerpflicht
gilt für alle die in unserem Land leben
ich bin überzeugt wir müssen diesen
Anspruch deutlicher formulieren als
bisher bloße Lippenbekenntnisse reichen
nicht reichen nicht in dieser Zeit des
Terrors und des Hasses und ich weiß dass
der Krieg im Nahen Osten insbesondere an
vielen Schulen im Augenblick zu heftigen
Auseinandersetzung führt viele
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer sich gefordert
über fordert oder gar alleinelassen
fühlen und ich erwarte von der Politik
dass sie Lehrerinnen und Lehrer in
dieser schwierigen Zeit mit aller
Entschlossenheit
unterstützt liebe Gäste der innere
Frieden das ist keine
Selbstverständlichkeit wir müssen ihn
verteidigen wo immer wir ihn verletzt
oder gefährdet sehen und jeder und jede
muss jetzt diesen inneren Frieden zu
sein einer persönlichen Sache machen sie
alle die sie heute meiner Einladung
gefolgt sind haben dieses friedliche
Zusammenleben zu ihrer Sache gemacht sie
alle setzen sich auf herausragende Weise
ein für Dialog und gegenseitigen Respekt
für ein friedliches Zusammenleben von
Juden und Muslimen in unserem Land Sie
leben religiöse Toleranz und
Verständigung in großartigen
Projekten und vor allem mit sehr viel
wie ich von ihnen weiß mit sehr viel
persönlichem Einsatz ich weiß dass
manche von ihnen mit schweren
Anfeindungen zu kämpfen haben und möchte
Ihnen sagen ich bewundere ihr
Engagement und ich freue mich über ihren
Mut dass sie trotz allem weitermachen
sie alle sind leuchtende Vorbilder wie
wir sie gerade jetzt so dringend
brauchen sie sind
Vorbilder für viele andere Menschen in
unserem Land und dafür möchte ich Ihnen
heute von GZ zum Herzen danken danke
dass Sie gekommen sind vielleicht haben
Sie auf Ihrem Weg
hierher auch bedrückende Gedanken
begleitet was können wir jetzt sagen wie
können wir jetzt durch unser Beispiel
noch etwas
bewirken und ich weiß das sind keine
leichten Fragen ich jedenfalls bin froh
über das Gespräch mit Ihnen bin sicher
ihre Erfahrungen ihre Sorgen auch ihre
Hoffnungen Ihre Wünsche für die Zukunft
die sind gerade jetzt für unser Land von
großer
Bedeutung erlauben Sie mir dass bevor
wir das Gespräch beginnen ich sie
wenigstens kurz
vorstellen darf beginnen mit unserem
ihreng Gast einem Gast den ich
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen muss
liebe Frau Friedländer ihre unglaubliche
Lebensgeschichte ist für uns alle ein
Wunder und ihre Haltung eine an der wir
uns eigentlich jeden Tag aufrichten
können sie haben miterlebt wie ihre
Eltern ihr Bruder viele Freunde und
Verwandte von den
Nationalsozialisten als Juden ermordet
worden sind sie selbst haben das KZ
Theresienstadt überlebt sind dann in die
USA ausgewandert erst mit 88 Jahren kam
sie zurück in ihre geliebte Heimatstadt
nach Berlin und seit setzen Sie sich
sich als Zeitzeugin vor allem an Schulen
unermüdlich für Versöhnung ein dafür
dass junge Menschen erfahren was damals
geschehen ist damit es nicht wieder
geschieht es ist für euch für die jungen
Menschen das sagen sie immer wieder
welche Freude Vau Friedländer dass Sie
heute hier sind herzlichen
Dank an ihrer Seite begrüße ich ganz
herzlich Derwisch
hisai ein Berliner wie auch Margot
friedlinder aufgewachsen in Neuköln als
Sohn türkischer Einwanderer sie
engagieren sich seit vielen Jahren
leidenschaftlich und den vielen Ämtern
und Initiativen gegen Antisemitismus
Diskriminierung und Rassismus sind
Vorstandsvorsitzender der schon lange
weit über Kreuzberg hinaus bekannten
kreuzbergerinitiative gegen
Antisemitismus schön dass Sie heute hier
sind unser nächstes gästepaar sie lieber
Michael Fürst und sie lieber jasit
schamut verbindet einerseits als
vorsitzend des Landesverbandes der
jüdischen Gemeinden
Niedersachsen und dann als vorsitzend
der palästinensischen Gemeinde in
Hannover etwas was alles andere als
selbstverständlich ist und das gilt auch
zu anderen Zeiten nämlich sie beide
verbindet eine tiefe Freundschaft und
eine gemeinsame Vision für friedliches
Zusammenleben in unserem Lande und ihnen
beiden ist es gelungen einen
erfolgreichen Dialog zwischen Jüdin und
Juden und PalästinenserInnen und
Palästinensern in Hannover zu begründen
gemeinsam haben sie nach dem 7 Oktober
dazu aufgerufen Hass und Hetze in gegen
zu treten ein herzliches Willkommen
ihnen
beiden uns nächstes gästepaar ist hier
in Berlin stadtbekannt sie lieber Jalil
dabid und sie lieber OSB David hätten
sich als Palästinenser und
Israeli vermutlich nie träumen lassen
dass sie einmal zusammen ein Restaurant
betreiben würden und das ausgerechnet in
Berlin und das tun sie allen
Anfeindungen zum Trotz und dann auch
noch sehr
erfolgreich das Kanaan ist bekannt für
seine Küche und sein Motto uniting
cultures through food oder wie es in
einem Film
einst ironisch optimistisch hieß make
Humus Not war lieber Jalil tabit ich
weiß dass sie gerade bei ihrer Familie
in Israel und auf der Westbank waren und
eigens für diesen runden Tisch
zurückgekommen sind nach Berlin
dafür herzlichen Dank mich hat das sehr
berührt sein sie uns beide herzlich
willkommen das nächste gästepaar Schai
Hoffmann und Joanna hassun lebt
ebenfalls in
Berlin als Deutsch israelischer
Sozialunternehmer und als
palästinensischstämmige
Geschäftsführerin von
transadency gehen sie seit Jahren
dorthin wo es besonders wichtig ist um
um Toleranz und Verständigung zu werben
in Berliner Schulen im Rahmen dieser
Projekte schaffen sie Räume für
Schülerinnen und Schüler um über
denostkonflikt zu sprechen wie
wichtig immer aber gerade und ganz
besonders in diesen Wochen danke ich
freue mich dass Sie beide hier
sind ganz herzlich begrüße ich auch
lieber Dimitri Belkin und lieber Akin
schimsek sie lieber Herr Belkin stammen
aus der heutigen Ukraine
leiten die Denkfabrik Shalom alikum eine
Forschungseinrichtung des Zentralrats
der Juden in Deutschland in der Themen
aus jüdischer muslimischer und
christlicher Perspektive diskutiert
werden dort arbeiten auch sie liebe Herr
schimschck außerdem sind sie Mitglied im
Vorstand der Alhambra Gesellschaft deren
Zieles ist jungen musliminen Muslimen
ein breites Angebot im Bereich der
politischen Bildung der Kunst und der
Kultur
machen seien sie uns beide herzlich
willkommen etwas ganz Besonderes
verbindet auch sie lieber Elias 3 und
er
Chitin sie beide engagieren sich als
Rabbiner und als Imam in dem wunderbaren
Projekt meet to respect besuchen
Schulklassen in denen sie für
interreligiösen Dialog und friedliches
Zusammenleben
eintreten sie vermitteln dabei
einerseits Wissen über den
Islam und betreiben andererseits
Antisemitismus
Prävention wie wichtig ist das
beides gerade in diesen Zeiten schön
dass Sie heute hier sind soweit die
Vorstellung meine Damen und Herren ich
denke wir alle sind gespannt auf dieses
Gespräch ich freue mich darauf
herzlichen
Dank
[Musik]